bitcoin from a price standpoint is not
yet at an all-time high even though it's
knocking on the door of the all-time
high but there's a couple of other key
metrics that we should be paying
attention to that are hitting all-time
highs first if we look at the chart for
the realized price of bitcoin we crossed
over a new all-time high 22 100 for the
realized price of bitcoin the way that
the realized price is calculated is it
looks at every single bitcoin that has
traded hands and those trading of hands
it calculates based on the price at the
time that it traded hands so if i bought
a bitcoin from joe at 100
that 100 ends up being the
piece added to realized price so for
example if i buy it at 100 bucks and i
hold it forever it's only contributing
100 to realize price market cap if i
then turn around and i sell it to joe at
62 000
now it counts as 62 000
to the realized price so it's the last
time that bitcoin traded hands what was
the price added all up you get realized
price that has now hit an all-time high
22 100
very very encouraging as you see some of
these underlying metrics these things
around usage or transactions starting to
hit all-time highs that usually means
that we are leading up to a price
all-time high in the actual price for
one bitcoin on top of that we have the
lightning network hitting an all-time
high in capacity last night it now is
coming in at
3101 bitcoin actually
locked up in the bitcoin lightning
network now what this means is you have
to actually lock your bitcoin and put it
as liquidity in the network to be able
to send value receive value or route
value and so of course when you put a
higher and higher amount it means that
the overall capacity of the entire
network continues to grow and so whether
it is the realized price of bitcoin
hitting an all-time high or the bitcoin
lightning network hitting an all-time
high these are both very encouraging and
then if we go and we look at the actual
bitcoin hash rate if you remember all
the way back in may china kicking out
many of the miners those miners having
to unplug their machines and either move
elsewhere or completely go out of
business but now we see the bitcoin hash
rate has come roaring back we now are
somewhere near where we were at the
beginning of the year and so to continue
to see this massive growth in the
bitcoin hash rate even though one of the
largest countries in the world had an
abrasive attack against it is very
encouraging this network is resilient
this network is going to continue to
become more and more secure over time
and my guess is before the end of the
year we will see a new all-time high in
the bitcoin hash rate as well now the
united states has been very fortunate to
step in as that leader over 35
of the bitcoin hash rate now resides
within the united states and likely to
go over 40 in the short term so what we
saw was a massive geopolitical mistake
by china and the united states had an
opportunity and it seized it the united
states is now the leader in bitcoin
mining and so as we see that growth
coming back online most of that growth
is coming online in the united states in
a democratic capitalistic society rather
than an authoritarian centrally planned
one and so when we start to look at all
the underlying metrics of bitcoin
whether it's the realized price whether
it's the capacity in the lightning
network or it is the hash rate it is
encouraging because we are seeing an
increase a positive impact of the
fundamentals of the asset the network
continues to be more secure more and
more people continue to buy and hold
bitcoin 85 of the supply has not moved
in the last 90 days which leads us to c
all the new demand is only competing for
about 2.8 million bitcoin in circulation
that are liquid and available to be
purchased
how bullish are we right now looking at
all these underlying metrics
really bullish
right like i i think uh we've gotten
past kind of all the fud right when it
comes to china and the hash rate and all
that other stuff with elon's previous
tweets and everything that was going on
and the fundamentals look really good
all the ones you just went over right
whether it's it's hash rate or the
supply squeeze uh kind of the bitcoin in
circulation all that stuff i think we're
setting up for a really good end of the
year and maybe even into q1 uh
continuing on the bull run that we
thought we were previously on before
some of that stuff derailed us a little
bit but the the on-chain metrics like
you just went through them right and
will and dylan have come on the show in
the past week and they've showed us all
this stuff that the fundamentals look
really really good uh look sublime
demand right when when the supply is
really low uh and the demand heightens
up from institutions other players
coming in etfs et cetera the price only
has one way to go john
yeah i mean it's bullish we've we've
kind of been preaching to the choir at
this point it's uh it's amazing to see
the hash rate something uh that's unique
obviously the us is going to be the
leader just based off the amount energy
that we probably already consume and the
amount of people that are adopting
bitcoin in the united states um but then
the next countries down the line india
russia japan are all up there with
energy uses um it's a 145 extrajules i
think it is and then the u.s is 85 and
then it drops significantly down to 30.
so it's no surprising to me about the
hash rate where is it going uh where are
people mining bitcoin the u.s i expect
that though a little bit to kind of um
disperse a little bit more globally
throughout uh throughout time i also
think that it's really interesting how
uh the hash rate not only has moved
geographically but also it feels like
the conversation around mining has
completely changed it was being attacked
both from oh there's a lot in china and
also from the energy impact but now all
of a sudden people are starting to warm
up to the idea wait a second this could
really help the oil and gas industry
there's a lot of things that could be
positive for the environment and also
now if it's within the united states
there's this element of like hey we
didn't like it when we couldn't make
money off of it oh now all of a sudden
it's an american thing oh now now we
really like it right and
i'm not saying that that's the way it
should be it just feels like now folks
especially politicians and and uh
regulators etc that's one of the
thoughts is like once they figured out
how they could make money now they're
really excited about this more tax
revenue more jobs creation more economic
prosperity i mean what if aramco gets
involved in it aramco is definitely
getting it i don't know when they're
doing i have no inside information but
aramco is definitely going to get
involved the economic incentive is way
too strong for them to continue to yeah
but like the whole thing for me when it
comes to the united states specifically
is like and other countries for that
matter is like this is clearly a growing
industry that's here to stay right like
at this point we're well beyond of like
hey is this a fad or not maybe you can
argue some of the things like if bitcoin
becomes a you know the global uh payment
system or whatever right there's a bunch
of kind of nuance to it that you can
argue over but the idea that crypto
payments and cryptocurrencies and crypto
assets and the platforms that are built
on top of them those are here to stay
right like that's already been decided
essentially in my mind right not only
from the talent perspective but how much
adoption it's already got in the growth
trajectory so why would you not want to
be a leader in that space right like
it's already it's already something
that's happening so the u.s deciding hey
we're going to try to get as much money
power as we can we're going to create
regulation we're going to foster
innovation in our country like that's a
no-brainer to me and if they don't do it
someone else is going to do it right so
they need to be the first one to adopt
all of that